ALEKSANDER BARKOV.
THEY START WITH SAM BENNETT,
BACK.
YOU SEE ALEX WENNBERG, LIFTING
HIS STICK.
HE GOES RIGHT RE IS MORGAN, BAC
TO THE
PANTHERS TONIGHT.
IT'S BACK  READY.
MacKENZIE WEEGAR.
HE GOT IT
>> Randy: QUICK SPEED AND PUCK
MOVEMENT BY THE SEATTLE KRAKEN.
FINISHED BY JORDAN
OBVIOUSLY, EARLIER IN THIS GAME,
JONATHAN HUBERDEAU HAD THE
SHORTHANDED BREAKAWAPANTHERS CL
CARTER VERERHE WILL PINCH IN.
BACK BEHIND THE NET.
LUCAS CARLSSON.
>> Steve: CROWD, TRYING TO
CHEER ON A 12
THEY HAVE TO COME ALL THE WAY
BACK.
OWEN TIPPETTTHEY THROW THE BODY
CHIPS  PATRIC
JOE THORNTON,  OFF  AS WELL.
LUCAS CARLSSON, DEFLECTED.
HE WAS
JAMIE OLEKSIAK, GETS THROUGH.
I DON'T KNOW IF GOAL RIGHT BACK
SAM BENNETT, COULDN'T SLANAN
RA
BOUNCING PUCK TOWARDS THE NET.
SUCH A HE POKES IT FREE.
THEY GOT A STICK ON IT.
PANTHERS HAD SOMETHING GOING
THERE.
IT'S RIGHT BACK IN.
HE SPARKED THE FORWARD LINES.
IT'S LOOSE IN FRONT.
BABA WAS STILL NOT A POWER PLAY
AARON EKBLAD, AGAIN.
IT'S OUT OF THE ZONE.
THEY HAV
PASSING.
, THE FIRST E NET.
THE FAR SIDE.
THAT WAS BLOCKED.
SPENCER KNIGHT, MAKES THE FIRST
IT GOES OVER.
PUTS IT IN FRONT. D
BY BMW, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
>> Steve: THIS IS WHAT THEY DID
TO WASHINGTON AND CAROLI
DESPERATE NEED OF A HAIRCUT.
THEY GET OUT T
THEY SEND IT TO SAM BENNETT.
THEY GET IT TOWARDS THE NET. LE
4-1.
>> Randy: THE PUCK